[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
please
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
oh
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
and there you go everyone welcome to the
panel from hell i'm jeff keeley a big
day
for baldur's gate three and we have a
lot of information to guys
about the game but first of all we
started with that incredible cg
you've seen some of that before but of
course the end was brand new
uh with the world premiere of the full
cgi intro
for baldur's gate 3 and from the looks
of it as you saw right there
we are going to hell in this game and
we're going to learn a lot about that
reveal
and so much more today uh but we're not
going to hell alone i've got some
special guests for this panel to give
you all the inside scoop
on early access for bg3 i'm joined by mr
larian himself
uh creative director's friend from
larian of course and
also dnd unicorn chris perkins from
wizards the coast and larian's legendary
writer adam smith uh guys i i have to
say
uh chris i guess you didn't get the memo
about the set here it's like
these guys no i did not i'm feeling
a little set ending this is well
he's got his armor i mean adam's got the
lights i love it you guys are full on
method it's look it's a big day
for uh bg3 fans we've been waiting for
details on early access and
i've seen the rundown guys don't worry
we are going to get a date out of these
guys by the end of this stream they
promised me
um but first of all uh let's talk a bit
about the game what was just revealed
uh sven uh the journey in bulger's
gate three actually start in avernus
which is you know the first layer of
hell here uh
tell us a bit about um what we just saw
and how that's gonna tie into the game
yeah so hi jeff and hi everybody uh so
we are in a lot of trouble we were
kidnapped we were
snatched by these mind players these
alien creatures
they put us aboard this nautoloid they
put a tadpole through our eye so that's
already not very pleasant
then they were chased by dragons they
tried to escape from these dragons
they decided it was a really good idea
to go to hell to avernus the first layer
of
the night to try to escape these red
dragons but these red dragons managed to
follow them
but not only that they managed to
teleport themselves right into the
middle of a big conflict between devils
and demons and so
me as a player i'm going to try to
figure out as a level 1 character
how the hell am i going to get out of
here and so our journey
begins in the middle of the blood war
and the the blood war is a is a big
thing
uh in uh dungeons and dragons and as a
matter of fact actually
uh chris uh recently together with his
colleagues at wizard of the coast
released a a book about that which was
uh descend into awareness
so the blood war um for those who don't
know is this
eternal uh battle between
demons which are kind of like evil
creatures of entropy that want to
destroy everything
and devils who are evil subjugators and
overlords who want to control everything
and that in and of itself doesn't sound
like a bad thing until you realize that
the blood war tends to spill
all over the place and onto other planes
pretty much anywhere and so it's really
just kind of bad for everybody
and it's been going on for such a long
time uh longer than
anybody can remember and is need to end
anytime soon
all right yeah and so and
and as far as as far as the hell if you
don't know much about the nine hells
there are nine layers of the hells and
avernus
is the topmost layer and
um that is where demons are constantly
invading and devils are constantly
trying to repel them
and so it's this tireless ageless
battleground
heaped with corpses and shattered
remains of flying citadels
like you saw in the introduction and
um
sorry yeah so we talk about in descent
into a vernis
uh there's a cataclysmic event where the
the blood war does
spill over uh into faerun and
uh it's a city called el torel which is
actually dragged into hell
uh this all happens in boulder's gate
descent into avernus the d d adventure
module
uh when we started to build bald escape
through we had to decide what actually
happened to
el torell at the end of that adventure
because like any good adventure like any
good role play game
there's many different ways that story
can go in our story
el torrel is actually it is saved
but that's not the end of it it's a
cataclysmic event it has aftershocks
that are still passing through the world
so when we regain control of the
nautiloid we actually
we bring ourselves back to fairview and
we crash land
and we crash land somewhere between
boulder's gate which is on the west and
the sword coast and el torrel
and we're going to see the aftermath of
el toro's
descent there are trains of refugees
traveling through this area and we're
going to get caught up in their stories
we can help them we can hinder them
we can get involved in their stories but
that's not our story
our story goes back to this thing
inside our brain and if you could talk a
little bit about that
like what that's actually doing inside
us right now
yes so mind flayers they're they're
awful
but mind flayers do not procreate the
way most other creatures do
the way they procreate is through a
process called seromorphist
in which they implant this parasite
into a humanoid host and over time
the parasite transforms the host
magically
into a fully grown adult mind flare
and it's an absolutely horrific and
disturbing process
um and uh once you become a mind flayer
of course
you don't have much in the way of
memories of your past
itself you are based one of them
so but this table of course is is a bit
different we already revealed
a little bit about that so as we start
panicking
and we figured out a way off out of hell
we are going to try to figure out how
the hell are we going to get rid of this
tadpole that's inside of us
and uh as we're doing that we'll we'll
learn things about the that will and
we'll learn that we
actually don't have a lot of days left
ahead of us and then suddenly some
strange starts happening
we start get great gaining strange
powers we start
uh not transforming into mind flair
which is which is good
we think and some of us in our party
start
thinking like maybe this infection is
not such a bad thing maybe
there's something to be sorry because
like uh for certain characters it's
actually solving problems that they have
in life
and so there's a rift that appears in
the party uh certain characters
uh say like well we we need to get rid
of this thing we can't leave it inside
of us
some say well maybe we should figure out
first what's going on here maybe we can
find a way of controlling it
and then uh others say like hell yeah
this is really cool we should join the
bad guys that are responsible for all of
this
and it's at exactly that moment that
hell comes back into
the storyline because a a nice gentleman
by the name of raphael makes his action
and he uh introduces himself very
rapidly
as a devil he's very open about and he
says well look i mean like
i'm here to propose you a deal and uh
the reason why i'm proposing a deal to
you is because you don't really care
about your soul anyway
because you don't have a soul anymore if
you turn into a mind flare your soul is
gone so
what do you have to lose and so
what's cool is that um in
multiplayer when you have uh
multiple players who are going to be
confronted by a raphael they get to
decide what they're going to do so uh
for instance chris you could say hell no
i'm never gonna
live with the stat pool and adam could
say well hell yeah i'm gonna do that
and i excited somewhere in between and
so maybe adam makes a pact with the
devil so he can get the best of him
chris i make a lot of mistakes
yeah obviously you know the the devil
you know the devil the motivation
um you know you talked about sort of you
know wanting your soul and these deals
um why why would you want to make a deal
well uh i think a lot of good adventure
begins with curiosity
uh you know i mean i'm an expert on
making mistakes so i will take this
uh i i may just be curious i may just
want to see what happens i may just
wanna
i may be seduced by the devil the
charismatic um
but fundamentally uh i have a serious
problem
and maybe this devil can't help with the
problem but uh chris if you could just
talk about what the devil wants in
return what do they actually want from
me
so in the nine hells soul are the
currency of the realm
for a devil to acquire a soul that's
great
for them because they can trade that
soul in
essentially to rise in power in the
in turkey that kind of rules the nine
hells
so that's really what they want souls
soul souls and
in order to get them though they have to
corrupt them first
they can't just grab anybody's soul they
have to lead
someone down a path where they keep
making bad decisions
evil choices and so that when they die
their soul
naturally goes to the nine hells that's
what the devil wants
to happen and so they're always
orchestrating um
events to try to make that happen
and they can do it through seduction
they can do it through deception however
they want to do it is fine
but that's their end game speaking of
uh decisions and choices uh
we're going to see a lot of game play
today and of course at the heart of
these games is you know decision and
choice for the players
um we're going to talk a bit about
crusher who will be uh returning here
for some interactive moments throughout
the stream
uh adam why don't you tell us a bit
about um pressure and crusher's role
yeah so we're gonna move away from
devils briefly and and look at a
situation
some of you may have seen before we're
going to see different aspects of that
so as a big shout out to the bg3
subreddit you guys know i love goblins i
love you
um this is a scene where we've actually
become friends with some goblins we've
actually gone into
goblins and we're interacting them in a
friendly way we've not gone in bashing
their heads we've decided hey
let's play cool with them so we're at a
party we're having a good time we're
having a real good time with these
goblins but then
we crush it and chris is obnoxious he's
unpleasant he's the guy who's
he's the death for the party uh so we're
gonna meet him
uh and we're gonna see how this
interaction goes i think now yeah
take a look
all right by the way nick is joining us
again he's going to be
driving the game play here and then lead
us all the way to crusher
and then you guys are going to get to to
make the decisions
while he's doing that can i just do it
like a big shadow
shout out try to make different
decisions than you did last time
community
so try to not make the same the same
same
decision so you can see how this pans
out differently it's up to you i mean
like but
i would sincerely advise you to go in a
different direction
we couldn't fix this humans
i know are you another pest dwarves
figure in the world
everyone says that and then they spare
our faces
but no more it's a changing
we got the absolute on our side now
you better learn your place
go on kiss more food
or i'll wipe that nasty look right off
your face
end him or leave him but don't you dare
grovel to this slug
all right do i need to rip your ear
shells off you heard me
there's our choice four options so in
the chat
uh you guys can select uh which one we
should
definitely choose here and then we'll
come back a little bit later in the
stream
and see how this sequence plays out
based on
the community but uh guys uh which one
would you
suggest the audience pick let's sway
them out of the four options here let's
start with you chris
i've got a bit of a a rogue temperament
and i'm kind of tempted by whatever that
is on it's on his foot there
so i'm of a mind to go with option one
all right sven and
oh go on sven all right no go ahead adam
go ahead well i i already said i'm a
friend of all goblins so i'm kissing
that goblin wherever he wants
to kiss
[Laughter]
i i'm intent on showing uh
players a a different outcome than they
picked last time i'm pretty sure they're
going to pick exactly the same thing
they picked last time because that's how
people are
but in the case that they want to follow
my advice i would suggest that we spin
in his face
i mean like i think that's a very
powerful
powerful move on top of that eliza is
going to prove of this so
i would i would just go for split him in
the face
all right well put in three of the four
uh you guys again vote in the chat and
then we'll come back in a few minutes
and we'll play out the sequence with
your choice and this will continue on
kind of throughout the stream
while we tally results in the chat uh
wanted to ask you guys
on just development of of bg3
how things are progressing on the game
uh you know obviously it's been a
difficult year for all of us and
especially game developers working from
home
uh in in this you know covid pandemic uh
world so sven wanted to ask you like how
is
development going we know we're gonna
get really an early access date out of
you guys hopefully by the end of the
stream here
um what's it been like to to make bg3
this year are things progressing as
you'd like
yeah it's uh it's going i mean like the
question how development is going ever
since we started on this i i think i had
the guys from wizards like ask me like
continue how's it going how's it going
how's it going so i'll be very happy
that we can say well actually we have
something
to show now so that you can actually go
and play and then i i think
people will like so but um it's going
it's slower than
uh we had hoped of course uh so
uh but we we're getting there we got uh
pretty much all of our content in there
we managed to get our recording studios
back online which was a big thing
so they're going to be recording the
final bits this month
uh so that's good uh we
are making progress uh work from home
luckily we have studios scattered around
the world so
um several of them are are booted up
again so we're working at 50 60
capacity so that's also really good so
we're in
a good shape to actually push this thing
through and
get it into the hands of players so that
at least they can start fooling around
with early access we would probably
already actually have been able to ship
early access if we hadn't
fallen into some of our old traps uh one
of these
is um our ability to underestimate
exactly
how much uh we have to add it seems like
we have this counter where we see like
okay these are the amount of dialects in
the game
this is the amount of dialogues that are
recorded this is the amount of
cinematics that are finished and that
counter is supposed to go to 100
and then we can ship the early access
content but i think this counter has
been doing it went from 70 to 80 to 90
to 80 to 70 to 60 to 70 to 80.
and so forth and recently has been
trying to get to 100
and it's been hovering around 95 percent
since forever
and so uh that has everything of to to
of course do with
the fact that for each dialogue we write
two new dialogues pop up
as um yeah edge cases appear
right adam yeah first of all
uh sorry
second of all uh there are multiple
reasons for this this is the first game
that
uh this scale that i've worked on and
one of the things that we
are very very keen to do is to make sure
this world is as reactive as we can
possibly make it
uh because that benefits all of you when
you play
so as we build a situation as we build a
quest as we build a dialogue what we
find is that
somebody within the team or somebody in
a different department might say well
i'd love to be able to do that or i'm
going to approach from this angle i'm
going to break the timing of this and
the chronology of it
and we don't say no we say yes and then
we adapt to that and we make sure that
the dialogue makes sense
that the way the world reacts makes
sense and that it remembers what you did
and that just adds complexity onto
complexity and
it makes for a really really satisfying
experience
and the other part of that is the
if somebody has a really cool idea then
it tends to find its way into the game
and we have a lot of really smart people
who have really good ideas
and those do end up in the game on the
whole
and it goes further than that sometimes
we have a very small idea
and it blossoms and it grows and it
ends up in the game and i think sven has
a particular example of something
that really demonstrates this and yeah
absolutely absolutely i got this i got
this real cool button that i am going to
hit right now for the first time he's
like
okay hit the right one yeah there you go
oh you know i like a good world cup
there you go yeah hold on wait until
you'll see until you see my other butt
so
um we
we we're a company that iterates a lot
as adam said and
we we give a lot of room for for what is
a good idea
uh so a couple of weeks ago and this is
literally only a couple of weeks ago
and uh i i picked this example
specifically because of that
one of our scriptures transformed
something that was a piece of scenery
into an interactive object and so we do
these regular reviews of the content and
we
were looking at this thing that said so
that's pretty cool and so then the
interactive object became a situation
and so we looked at that situation
oh that's that's really cool and then
that situation the scene where you can
recruit a follower and say whoa
this is really really cool and then now
there's a an entire
movement within the company trying to
make this follower into a companion
which is where
i said okay stop so we're not going to
start doing otherwise we're never going
to end
but it is a it's a very cool example of
how the game gets better how it gets
evolves pretty much like a tabletop
campaign would go together with the
players in this case
the players are the developers and uh
and it's also something i'm very proud
of of what the team did because
you literally have to realize that what
you're about to see right now two weeks
ago did not exist
and it was just a stupid object
somewhere sitting on the line
of a nautaloid so i'm going to hit my my
button again and then
uh we're going to have a look at uh or
oh there's my button again
what have you seen all right let's look
at it
yes you've come to save us from this
place
from this place you'll free us
[Music]
the exposed brain quivers in expectation
please please before they return
they return
a newborn borneo from this husk
you realize you're talking to an
intellect devourer
a minion of the mind flayers who
abducted you
[Music]
remove us from this body from this case
free us
[Music]
please
you notice edema a swelling of the brain
causing pressure where it strains
against the shell of
the skull
the brain lifts from the skull but you
notice an
opportunity you could [ __ ] the
strange creature
making it more subservient should it
prove a threat
[Music]
creature seems unaware of your
interference
it relaxes in your hands
[Music]
we are free our freedom is ours
friend the creature pauses
listening something behind your eyes
seizes in recognition we must listen to
the hell
at the helm we are needed
[Music]
us we are us
to the hell will we go we are going to
the home
isn't that awesome
all right well we got to find out a
little bit more lore about this
friend the intellect of our chris uh
tell us about it intellectual first of
all that was super gross but also
awesome
um intellect devourers are
creatures made by players out of the
brains of humanoids
the mind players have arcane rituals
that they can cast upon the brain
and then transform it into the creature
that you saw
now what's dangerous about an intellect
devourer once it's been created
is it itself
has these psychic powers and can
psionically or psychically bombard
you causing your brain essentially to
turn
to slush and then once it has destroyed
the brain in your skull it teleports
into your skull body
replaces your brain and basically
operates you
like finn's got one right there
operating up i gotta i'm trying to eat
it but my armor is
stuck
i got this awesome stuff from our
promised apartment
and so hold on hold on because it didn't
get better we are now
we're now selling them on
shop.larion.com they come
like this you can't have a little
ventilator right i'm kidding i'm kidding
it's not true
it's not true anyway chris i interrupted
you i'm sorry
oh that's totally cool so
what's obviously disturbing is you could
be talking to somebody and not realize
that their brain has been replaced with
an intellect of hour
basically you're into a meat pot
not me though so all right
so
there you go yeah and so in in in bg3
actually because of the tadpole that you
have
you learn that you can actually
communicate with all these mindflayer
related creatures
and you can command them they can try to
command you so you got this entire
interaction going on with them
but uh just going back to what i said
before
um i thought it was pretty amazing that
the team
managed to to to pull off this scene so
fast and it goes to show
what we've been doing all these years as
we've been working on bg3 we made this
gigantic uh household like ella
situation production machine
where if somebody comes up with a great
id they can put it into the game
fairly fast link it uh to everything in
there they got a whole bunch of tools
that support them
because now that us is because that's
what its name is
is uh in the tutorial other characters
had to react to it is it present in your
party
as us following you so they need to
start reacting to that so that's the
permutations that adam was talking about
and that came about really fluently when
you looked at it how
how um the the development of it was
going
and it goes from i mean this started
with scripting uh
writer jumped on it then the entire art
team jumped on it together with the with
the animators
and cinematic guys the sound guy guys
there's a lot of talent in just making
that little scene that needs to be there
and i just find it amazing that that
they can get this and it shows how far
the studio has come actually since we
started working on
on vg3 back in 2017. so
we have now this huge machine that can
support uh lots of choices and where
we're
heavily uh abusing it let's put it that
way
never-ending content but yeah that's i
mean that's a fun sequence and
obviously uh you guys uh have been
building
so much content that we're gonna talk
about i mean the amount of stuff that's
in early access we'll get to it but i'm
pretty blown away with what you guys
have put together
um so let's check in with our friend
crusher now and see what the audience
uh wants to do next we have the results
of the poll in
and it looks like 41 of you
picked to intimidate uh him with uh
how about you kiss my feet instead so
um what's the obvious let's
take a look
nobody listens to me
that that that's exactly what they
deserve for not listening to me
you ain't got nothing on me so kiss my
foot
i suggest an apology that's i i do too
all right i couldn't read what you did
nick all right
all right the next choice there four
more options so again in the chat
take your pick there about uh how you
wanna kiss the foot and then
uh we will uh we'll follow that up in a
second and see what people
select um this time around uh all right
so uh
we've seen a glimpse of avernus goblins
intellect devourers um a lot of folks
watching this i think want to know
early access we're gonna get a date out
of you but also like the content
of a um what can we expect in terms of
the scale and scope of what you're going
to
put out into the world for players to to
you know play around with
fun i'll take this actually
okay yeah now i'm gonna take it sven
uh i i think that um as you say you've
you've already seen just for early
access you've got multiple planes of
existence we're showing you of earnest
uh we're then taking you to faerun and
when you get to faerun you're going to
see
dungeons and dragons which you might
expect you're going to see temples
you're going to see
a big chunk of gameplay in on the
surface world
a lot of it we haven't shown yet you'll
get to meet those goblins you'll get to
meet a lot
of other people as well and we've
already
teased the underdark he will be going to
the underdog there's a lot to say
there's a lot of secrets and mysteries
down there
there's a lot of danger down there as
well uh you're going to meet a lot of
different characters
uh some of them you may recognize your
dnd fan he already met volo previously
and he made a brief cameo i think uh
uh earlier today for an eagle eyed who
spotted him uh
but you will meet lots of different
characters many many different
characters you're going to
see different factions of which are
recognized some that we've invented
ourselves
and of course there's going to be a lot
of monsters on the surface and in the
underdark
and those monsters include
world
epilept now chris
could you tell us what a bullet is
yeah a ballette is a terrifyingly large
monster that sometimes goes by the name
land shark and what it does as its name
suggests
is it burrows under the ground just
below the surface
churning up the earth as it goes while
it hunts
and then when it sees something it wants
to eat on the surface it bursts up out
of the ground
to chomp on it and it's it's big and
terrifying that's all i'll say
i mean you have so much content in ea
i know we were talking earlier you
thought you know 20 plus hours of stuff
for folks to um
to play around with so um you know lots
of stuff to it
um and i think people probably want to
know also about you know
the classes like you know what classes
are going to be available what level
will be able to reach in early access
can you give us any kind of details
there
um sven on what we can expect
uh yeah i know so because we are
since we're still building the early
access content we're still uh
slightly hesitant to announce all of the
classes that are going to be in there
uh but i think that we should be able to
cover at least a few of them chris what
do you play actually
for the moment what is it what would you
play
i often i often play rogues
i'm also a fan of fighters and i like
rangers because um they're
in touch with the primeval natural world
all right those are my favorites well
we'll have all of those covered so that
that's our that's already something
and there'll be more so we'll have a
selected we'll have a
a action of classes that are going to be
in there and we'll have
quite a few races quite a few sub races
um
we don't know exactly how many are going
to be there it depends on a couple of
assets
uh we uh are going to allow you to
create your own custom character
so uh when you'll see character creation
we should be presenting it
soon enough you will see you get a lot
a lot of customizability as a matter of
fact the stream
will show a bit of gameplay that i just
burst or stumbled upon
by fooling around in character creation
and like just picking an option and said
oh my god i start with that and now i
can do that
and that is really cool so uh you'll be
able to create
uh yeah a a right selection of custom
characters
and will let you in early access play up
to level four now before you go saying
what only level four
level four in dungeons and dragons is
actually quite a lot already can you
maybe help us explain that uh chris sure
well the good news is is that you're not
as frail as you were when you were level
one uh so you can take a bit of
punishment but
more importantly is once you get to
level four you've already made some
key character defining decisions for
instance
your your class you've chosen a sub
class
which is sort of like a way to
specialize within your class
and not only have you chosen a subclass
but you've probably had the option to
choose a
feat which is a mechanic that lets you
further customize your character and
gives your character access to new
ability
um and so and obviously if you're a
spell caster
by the time you hit fourth level you're
starting to get some fairly interesting
spells
even the level four yeah i was going to
say you're still going to struggle when
we throw a landshark at you
you're still going to get shot yes but
yeah
thankfully you be traveling alone
uh in early access there are five
companions that you can recruit
that you'll meet during your journey uh
i'll briefly
mention who they are uh you will have
met some of them already you've been
following that development
uh but here's a quick rundown so there's
will uh he's a human warlock you might
feel
either very at home or very alarmed by
where i am right now
uh the shadowheart who's a dark cleric
on a mission from her goddess esterian
who's a very unusual character he's a
vampire spawn so he has some unique
mechanics
uh elizal who's a githyanki warrior who
you see in the cgi intro
you see the dragon riders there as well
she's not with that group but
they are the githyanki so she knows a
lot about mindflows so she's a very
interesting character
and there's gail and gail's a human
wizard who has
more things going wrong inside him than
just the tadpole but we'll say no more
about that
now with all these companions uh i think
everyone wants to know you know can
friends play companions are we gonna get
multiplayer in uh
at least in ea
so not instantly so we'll move uh we'll
do it to play as one of the origin
characters later on and that'll give
people the opportunity to get to know
the companions from a third person point
of view if you want just by recruiting
them
i gotta say uh depending on which
companions you
you you pick we talked about
permutations earlier
you'll get a completely different
experience like if you uh for instance
if you take shadowheart and lyzelle
they can't stand each other so that
gives you completely different dynamics
than if you take characters that
actually
like each other so you should be able to
have a lot of fun fooling around with
these things
uh and we will have multiplayer in there
so uh
you will be able to play with a party uh
of up to four
uh you'll be able to play online you'll
play and be able to play in lan
we won't have split screen available
from the get-go but that will be added
at some point uh
during development also so there's going
to be quite a lot of
things that you can fool around with
because between the class choices that
you have and the race choices that
you'll have and the choice of companions
that you can have
that's already when you start adding up
all the permutations and you see what
it means in game to have made those
choices that's already a lot of content
that is going to be present in there
yeah you talked a little earlier about
like still figuring out quite what
classes will be available ea i mean it's
like there's still things to be done
but i know we're we're gonna pin you
down on a date
uh by the end of the stream you promised
what what is there left to do kind of
between
now and when you let the world in for
early access on the game
so i don't think we're gonna add much
more characters
like us last minute anymore so that was
just really because they were still
working on the tutorial area
i have to say the tutorial area is not
finished yet so we need to finish that
one
uh we got the act one that adam talked
about that's done
so all the content is there we're still
bouncing there's some assets
like the bullet that we talked about
earlier on right now it looks like a
bear because they're using the place
hoarder for bear but
which is terrifying when it comes out of
the ground
it's actually it's pretty cool actually
it chases you around the underdark so
it comes out at the most inopportune of
time so it's a rather interesting
encounter
especially because it mingles with other
encounters and you don't know when it's
going to happen and it's like it freezes
you because you're you're almost dead
and then suddenly the bullet is there
and he said
no like so we'll see how that works in
early access people hate it or not
uh so but we're doing play
tests now actually we have a bunch of
people
that are going to be passing by uh in
the next couple of days and so that will
be going on until early access and we'll
do balancing against them we'll get rid
of the most
obnoxious ui things that might be in
there that we have overlooked
so we'll try to fix the most prominent
books and then the last bit that
is really if if there's one thing that
at this point i think
might cause a slight delay in addition
to the date that i
i'm about to announce oh my god here's
the here's the app
this is yeah it's the asterisks it's the
optimization so
the game is coming out for both pc and
stadia
we want to get the minimum specs fairly
low
so that a lot of people can already
start fooling around with it
so there's a bunch of optimizations that
need to happen uh
and optimizing is a it's a very special
um
profession uh in the sense that every
single time you optimize something only
then do you discover what the next thing
is that you have to optimize
so these guys are literally driving
blind in the realm of obstacles of uh
of optimization so they're they're
feeling moderately optimistic i mean i
had a
lunch with them today and they were
actually they were in good moods so
that's good
because usually they're panicking so
we'll see how it goes so it's looking
it's it's looking okay and um
i'm i'm optimist by nature so i'm just
going to stick to that and so i
hope that everything is going to work
out i was going to say we still
dated don't pull the date at the end we
need to get a date
obviously there's you know so much to
this we will give you
guys a date don't worry but sven's
always super honest with everyone about
stuff
um so yeah we want to talk a bit more i
think about you know the game
of uh what you're gonna get in early
access on act one but before we do that
uh let's check back with crusher to see
what you guys
picked uh and based on the last prompt
uh it looks like 65 of you
picked to kiss his foot and attempt to
steal the ring so we're about to see a
uh
ring heist guess let's see how this goes
down
[Music]
you deserve all of that you didn't
listen to what i said
lavender it gives way to the muddy taste
of something
better left without description
you enjoying that disgusting
slimy stinking
faith i'll rip your fingers off
well you ruined that all right i think
he's gonna have a lot of fun trying to
get to the next
to the next section let's see if he's
going to manage
to do that so there's a video and we're
looking at this disaster
in the making
uh yeah this is this is not gonna this
is not gonna end well
uh although nick i mean like he's i
didn't introduce him he's our lead
system designer so he might actually
manage uh to get something sorted out
i wanted to chat about something as
we'll let nick in the background do
that i i wanted to chat about something
that we didn't talk about yet is how
uh the early access content of um
original sin 2 compares to baldur's gate
3 actually it's a bit i wanted to talk
about
to give you an idea of exactly how much
is in there can we
you can are we going to watch the entire
combat
cut away i think from it will take some
time with that on his own
yeah yeah i know there's so much stuff
we were talking earlier about like the
amount of dialogue and stuff
in this early access compared to
previous early access like this is like
there's a lot of content right thank you
jeff i wanted to drop that because i
looked up the numbers and they're
they're pretty impressive actually when
you look at it so baldur's gate 3
early access has 80 potential combats
compared to 22
in or two as early access version and
the dialogue lines in
original sim 2 we had 17 600 lines in
all of act one
we have 45 980 lines at at the moment
in bg3 when you look at the amount of
spells and actions that are available
from the get-go in early access so for
those two that was 69
and here we'll have 146 and then when
you look at the amount of characters and
that's by far the most impressive one
original sin 2 it was 142 characters
that you encountered in act 1
and here we have 596 in bg3
early access version so the
i'm saying these numbers because you're
it doesn't mean that you're going to
play
that much longer when you're going to
play the early access version of vg3
compared to those two
but it's just testimonial to the amount
of choices that you're going to get to
make because you won't have to do those
80 fights it really depends on what
choices you make
you will never see 46 000 lines of
dialogue it really depends on which
spots you took
which class you selected which
companions you had and so forth with
choices members
and so the uh but it is really like um
i've
i thought boss 2 was very intellectually
challenging already just to maintain the
overview
but then when you look at bg3 it's like
it's so much it's
such a higher level i mean i think adam
maybe you can chat a little bit about
what it
what that means uh on your side from the
way where you're sitting when you're
writing these dialogues
yeah i mean the the the the number is
important obviously but really what's
important is that
that they're interesting that they're
quality and that they are
responsive to the way you play so we
don't want to deliver 45 000 lines of
dialogue to you as a speech we want you
to discover them we want you to interact
with them we want these to feel like
conversations
so you're going to get on a playthrough
the ones that feel right for your
playthrough
and i'm going to do something that uh
i'm going to implore you all we know
that most people tend to be good people
when they play crpgs uh it's it's the
metric shows that
what i'm going to ask you to do if you
play early access
uses an excuse to do the bad thing
i want you to be your worst version of
yourselves because
some of my favorite favorite situations
and characters in this game you may not
even
speak to if you don't try those evil
roots we don't want this to be
you clicking the hero button or you
clicking the villain button we don't
want it to be like that
we want the world to react to the things
you do and we want you to
have reasons for doing them so if you're
doing something terrible in this game
you can probably justify it because
you're in a bad situation
but you can also just be really bad
and we're gonna meet some of these how
many characters 596 some of those
characters you'd never speak to
some you just kill if you're playing the
good option and
some of them have really interesting
stories to discover so i i beg of you
be evil just this once but be good in
your life
so early access is a really good
opportunity for this
it is gonna say it's a good place to
explore these things
and uh and this all goes back to
us approaching this game and trying to
be as close as we can to like your
digital dm and i think
chris you know this is something that is
true with dungeons and dragons and
tabletop role-playing in general
it's it's a place where you know people
gang together they do
they want to be heroes sometimes and
sometimes they just want to burn the
world right
oh we lost chris there i lost chris's
audio for a second
yeah sorry i had i was muted
my dog was american i'm sorry uh so i
made it myself but
i i agree with you wholeheartedly uh
flirting with evil has been a part of
dnd since the beginning
it's uh it's it's good not to be evil
because evil parties tend to implode but
once in a while uh it can make the story
going fascinating direction
yeah absolutely um one thing that you
know we talked about
options obviously good versus evil
play-throughs but let's also talk about
permutations uh and you know the further
expanded
uh set of options in the um in the game
how
how is that going to work them um in you
know
in the game in terms of permutations and
choices
so it begins yeah yeah
it it starts like for us it's like we're
inviting you into our world into our
campaign into the world of dungeon
dragons and from the minute that you
choose your class and your race we're
paying attention as writers and as
designers
and the world's going to react to that
it's going to react to who you are at
the beginning of your adventure
but more importantly and the more
complicated part is it's going to react
to
the things that you do your part is
going to react to the way that you
behave
uh your party is going to react to to
each other they're going to have these
these complicated relationships that
develop
what we want to do is we want the world
to always be aware of you
so so it's a lot of work to make sure
that you
that you get all that and that's what we
mean by permutations we mean
reactivity we mean a world
that makes you feel like you're really
part of it and that we've invited you in
and we've let you we've let you play
with it and and and it will
react to you uh not just tell you its
story
uh and it's it's it's a lot of work and
if you think of it from a dm perspective
we have this huge
huge detailed uh world that we created
all these different quests and
storylines
and what happens sometimes is you invite
somebody like sven into them
and they they they do something
that you didn't expect and anything
which says oh you know what i'm not
going to engage with this stuff i'm
going to do something completely
different this is what sven discovered
the other day
i was pulling around with i was fooling
around
with with character creation and i
always want to see how i can break the
game that's pretty much my job
description
uh and so i picked a ranger and so i had
a glass passive that i could select so i
picked
a beast taming because i read that it
was going to give me
a cantrip which allows me to find a
familiar and i always likes familiar so
i said well i want it familiar
so let's try it out and see what damage
i can do with my familiar and like
because one character here i instantly
could go and get a recruit that familiar
and so uh nick can you fire that up
the uh is that gonna work out
yeah all right nick has two machines
that he's operating so he's about to
report in how his combat went i think it
went disastrous
uh so here you see him uh
summoning a spider so he has a whole
bunch of familiars that he could have
picked he could have picked a crap
or a cat or a raven or some something
more interesting
but the spider is also pretty cool and
so and the thing is that he can then
take
control of the spider and so that's the
thing that i started fooling around with
and actually that spider went the entire
other side of the world and
so i went with my spider and i listened
in on conversations
and i i went to look at what all the
evil guys were up to and the amazing
thing was that in
in general it actually worked and so
that was pretty cool so
i called can you do a little jump nick
because he the spider has this really
cool jump
i remember gail of verticality so just
that ability the ability to jump far as
this spider
that alone already allows you to do a
whole bunch of things
but the spider can also cause mayhem can
you go and bite maybe
so this is a a little bit further
there's a character called shadowheart
she's one of your companions
so maybe bite her bite her in her leg or
something
there we go oh
critical oh she didn't she didn't feel
it do it again nick
oh my god she doesn't react she's
supposed to react oh no
it's failing alive oh there no okay so
she is reacting i guess she didn't feel
it through her
chain mother so things like we we
chatted actually after
after me doing and i said are you going
to put a leash on this because that's
normally what a developer would do right
they would say okay well you can't allow
this to do it's going to break the
entire game you have to make sure that
you can maximum go 20 meters away
or some silly rule like that and so we
looked at each other and said nah we're
just going to leave it in there
i mean it works for the most cases so
let's see if the scriptures can make it
work across the entire game
and so the one limitation that we put on
there is that the spider can't go
through doors
so that's it they can't open the door oh
obviously they would be able to go
through doors but with them to do level
transitions
but other than that you can take your
familiars uh you can take a cat
you can send your cat somewhere and then
you can uh get the cap
to um what's it called draw people's
attention has a different name
but draw people's attention so that
people start looking at the cat which is
great for your rook as he's sneaking
through
somewhere in the dark so all this
systemic gameplay comes into play
just by that one little choice you know
i just selected beast taming and gave me
a cantrip
find familiar and now i have all these
new options so now i imagine that you're
playing in multiplayer and you're doing
all these crazy things and now i imagine
that you're the scripts who have to
think of all the permutations that are
going with this
and so that is one of the the things
when we're talking about permutations
but we have more actually uh
we um nick could you manage to get
yourself into a situation with he has
all these save games and so
uh can you get into a situation with
animal empathy
or an animal talking while maybe chris
explain to people
what the difference is between animal
handling and uh speaking with animals
i don't know wait wait we'll let
christopher explain first
can we jump back to chris please yeah
we can't hear him our muted
no you're muted crystal
you can hear me now though right
a yeah in dnd and you use it to
uh convince animals to do things
um and it's not like
specifically these are animals you're
not talking to you're just saying okay
there's a horse over there
that doesn't like me i want to change
its mind about me
or there's a wolf that wants to eat me
i'm going to try to persuade it not to
and or maybe feed it some other food and
convince it leave me alone
those are great uses for the animal
handling skill
whereas speak with animals the spell
allows you to have a two-way
conversation
with a beast
and so when we when we were starting to
prepare development for the game
we looked at animal handling and we
obviously had done a game in which you
could speak with animals with divinity
original sin and say so what are we
going to do are we going to put
handling in yes or no because it
actually means we need three dialogues
and we need to dialogue when you click
on an
animal where you're just not handling
the animal we need the dialogue that
you're handling the animal we need
a dialogue that you're speaking with the
animals that means every single animal
is going to come with at least three
dialogues not counting the permutations
that are going to come out of this
and so then we looked at each other and
said well we have no choice really we
have to do all of it
and so this is how we we brought animal
handling
to the game as many other things and so
we'll we'll have a look at what animal
handling looks like in the game but
first
i have a question for for chris if you
were to
uh dm a a campaign and
someone wanted to try animal handling on
an albert will you allow it
oh yeah i would allow it because an
albert even though it's
classified as a monstrosity in the dnd
game as opposed to
just an ordinary beast it has a very
animal-like brain
so yeah i would definitely allow it
excellent because that's literally what
we said and so
i was gonna say
uh you know you've got living things you
can speak to obviously
uh owl bears spiders
right we should see them
can we keep in mind as you watch this
that chris just referred to this as a
[Laughter]
monstrosity
wow this is cool are you going to try
animal handling now
so bear in mind if you had secret
animals he could have talked to yeah
yep uh so we're not going to spoil
everything tonight uh so but the
double bear cup uh if you manage the
situation really well
uh leads up to multiple other situations
in which you find that all back up and
if you
really really play your cards well and
your dice roll well
then you can actually recruit that
albert cup in your camp and then you can
see the things that happen in your camp
now it wouldn't be bg3 if
what happens with the alberta cup and
the depend on what other animals you
brought there
so the old world cup could create quite
a lot of havoc so if you had a favorite
pet dog there it might
might be that you wake up one morning
and your favorite pet dog might have had
a small accident so these are things
that you need to take into consideration
as
as you're playing the game but they're
the cool fun situations that that roll
out
and all of this is brought to you
cinematically also throughout the entire
game
and that's where those those well not
only where does 45
lines of dialogue come from because we
have yet another example of
things that that bloated or dialogue
counts and then maybe you want to chat
about that one adam
i was gonna say it's like there's even
more right
yeah no like uh we thought if you can
speak to the animals you can do the
animal handling you can speak to
all these different creatures you can
speak to goblins you can speak to people
you can speak to get the yankee and then
we thought well
there are other things that you can
speak to in the world dungeon dragons
and that's
dead things so uh we also allow you to
be dead because we didn't have enough
dialogues already and
thankfully dungeon dragons does have a
rule for that so speak with dead is
implemented in the game if
chris you could just explain how that
works in fifth edition
yeah so this is
a necromantic energy and it allows you
to have
to ask questions to five questions of a
corpse now the corpse needs to be
relatively intact
so that it has like a working mouth or
something it can use
that's one uh condition um the other
of course is the corpse only knows
things that happened
prior to death
also the corpse is not always
necessarily friendly
to you um and
as precise an answer as you want
so when we were young you cut away from
me there
did you guys hear me i i i didn't hear
him
oh you're back yeah he's back he's back
back alive
okay i didn't there's nothing wrong on
my end it was just this thing in the
system i guess
but i was going to say so speak with
dead is a spell that lets you
talk to a corpse
and you can ask it five questions
go on all right are we yeah
all right you're good we're gonna hear
you next time to communicate across the
void
uh so yeah so it's it's it's five
questions
and the the uh the head needs to be
intact and we could have gone the route
of just making sure that everyone who
died had their head explode or you
decapitated them we didn't
uh so there are a lot of dead people
that you can talk to in the game
and we've we've implemented as close as
to d d rules as
as we could and we've got a pretty cool
uh take on it i think and i think we can
look at one of those right
yeah that's that that is correct
so this is actually on the very beach
where you will crash with your ultraloid
after
you play the tutorial area so we've
shown this area uh before
but there's bodies lying there and so
he's going to
take a scroll speak with that and then
he's going to have a chat
so
marcus fisherman
obviously the crash came quick
trying to help folk
i personally wouldn't have wasted my
scroll to this guy nick i don't think
that was a really good idea
but anyway uh so again we're not gonna
start spoiling things too much because
we do want players to discover things
for themselves uh but so when you add
all of these things now suddenly that
number of 45 000 starts making sense
especially when you then take
all of the different types of
playthroughs that you can have of the
content so
it is a incredibly reactive game with a
lot of
uh choices that are made available to
you as a player
in this particular case chris which
classes do you can you use speak with
that ass
because not everybody can speak with
that for instance yeah i mean well if
you have a spell scroll that's really
handy but a
cleric for instance is very handy with
speak with deads
and uh so if you have a cleric in the
party that's a good start
yeah so that that's another example of
how which classes you have in your body
actually define what gameplay options
are going to be available to you so
uh and when the full version of the game
is going to release one will have all
classes in there
it's going to become very very hard to
get out of character creation because
you'll have to make some decisions that
will have lots of ramifications
uh as you you go across the game
uh i got news from uh
well from crusher so it didn't end well
what's latest what's that
so i'm i'm picking up that he died
miserably
all right and so he hasn't been able to
get back into the
into the situation that he so we're not
gonna see
the the end of crusher unfortunately uh
so that that's going to bring me
probably closer to to one of the
problematic things which is going to be
the release date i guess
is that correct because exactly this is
the awkward part of the stream but
we are gonna do a q a at the end
for the community as well so if you guys
have questions for these guys
um that's your next interactive thing to
do in chat is you're not gonna get to
pick the final question all but you can
throw a question at these guys so put
those in the chat and then at the end
we'll we'll come back and do some uh
some q a with these guys
as well um on what happened but yes
uh we are going to talk about the early
access release date in a minute here
um but let's let's talk like
philosophically about
early access you're here addressing many
of the fans watching are folks that are
going to be i'm sure jumping into early
access
um what does that kind of mean to you as
a studio like how you know early access
is a term that people throw around in a
bunch of different ways and
sometimes it's just you know literally a
marketing beta or something i mean i
know
you guys treat this part of the
development of the game um
can you maybe talk a bit spend like
philosophically about like
what you're looking as a studio to get
out of early access you'll get feedback
sure but like how is it going to affect
the game and your approach to finishing
it up to 1.0
i like that you're asking me these
philosophical questions with a brain in
my hand so it's really cool
uh so to be or not to be so um
yeah i know um so we did uh
early access for uh original sin one and
we liked it a lot because it helped us
to make originals in one a much better
game
so we went full in for original sin two
in early access and that made originals
into a much much much better game
and so we're hoping to to get the same
uh out
of early access for the g3 so we're
going to go into early access and we
intend to stay there for a while
as we improve everything that our
community doesn't like about it
uh everything that we see is problematic
and the way we're going to do that
is uh we're going to and on the one hand
we're going to do a whole bunch of
analytics
and on the other hand we're going to
listen to what the community is telling
us and so the analytics
we use tools for that that that joe
always thinks i mean i think we have
some
um uh heat maps from original sin too
that we can show exactly how you show me
this is so cool
yeah yeah so what are we looking at
that's where those two that's a heat map
of the early access
part of act one and that's how where
people were dying
so if you played those two and you look
at the lower part on the
on the left side there's a big red spot
that's a guy named migo
everybody who played those two will
remember me go because everybody pretty
much died there so we could see that
everything was
as it should be and so if the entire map
becomes red it means that we have
problems
uh if we see and then typically we're
going to lower the difficulty of a fight
uh
if we see that there's areas where
nobody's coming and then we say okay
this is too hard to find so maybe we
should give
a little bit of a hint and then we
modify the level design a little bit
so it's things like that but then it's
also things like
our spells being used or maybe we should
promote a class and explain to people
well you can do these things
do they actually figure out that they
can speak with the debt maybe they never
figure it out because they don't think
it would be possible so
we then tell them through a tutorial box
hey you can speak with the debt
we spend like this amount of thousands
of dialogue lines on it please try to
speak with that it's pretty
pretty cool
the forums but we gamepl read them and
then we use what they tell us to drive
internal debate over
how will we change things like one of
the really big examples from original
sim 2 was
we had this thing called durability
people hated it
vehemently they really really hated it
they like hated it intensely
and so they came up with a whole bunch
of arguments and so
eventually we listened to it we were
stubborn but we eventually listened and
made a better game out of it and so
hopefully the same thing is going to
happen here with bg3 because it's
certainly not easy to translate
a rulebook that's been around for some
time that has so much fans into a video
game
and then trying to do justice to the
rulebook but also make sure that the
video game is a lot of fun so we have to
find
a very fine line in between there and
there's many many possible
interpretations
and so we came up with our
interpretation but now we'll let the
community
judge it and then if they come up with
better ideas
same thing like what you saw with the
intellect of order we'll just adapt and
we'll
we'll put it in there and in the end it
is about
i guess creating a story with the
community creating a game together with
the community just like
a what we do i think chris right so if
you're creating your campaigns
you go along with what people tell you
exactly dnd is a shared storytelling
game
so best ideas come from all around you
know
excellent yeah i'm sure the community
but i say we know where our story's
going
and we know uh the various terrible and
wonderful ways that this story can end
and the different place it'll take you
to
but uh as storytellers we we
want the audience to be part of that and
that that works for me as a writer
within larian you know people play my
work every day people look at my work
everyday and you become better through
that you become better by listening you
become better by engaging and
storytelling is very collaborative
so if there are characters just as in a
table
campaign if there are characters that
people particularly love or particularly
hate
then we may notice that and uh and you
know it's already happening we're not
even in early access yet but
we see you guys talking and we see the
things that
amuse you and that you're interested in
and you know we do pay attention
um so it's uh you know may the people
you're on sven
many people want to know with the
uh you know early access most people
watching this stream i'm sure are folks
that
are likely to probably jump into ea but
who is
early access for um
and when you think of it i mean it
obviously is not affinity but something
that i know you want to get many people
into to play it but
in terms of setting expectations and
kind of the the
audience for it um who are you targeting
for for early access if there is like a
prototypical player you'd want in early
access
yeah so how we we so
i know who we're not targeting it's the
person who wants a finished polished
game they should wait they should
just wait until version 1.0 because
we'll we'll work very hard on making as
polished as we can but it's not that yet
early access is for fans who want to
have a a quick look like an early feel
of what it's going to be like and
there's a lot of fun to be had there's a
lot of stuff to be seen
already so uh so i think that it's
that's one group
then it's also for people who really
want to be part of development who just
want to give us as much feedback as they
can
we'll play over and over and we'll just
engage
uh with with us on in the forums and and
then just
give us lots of data to look at and also
give us lots of ideas to work with
and so we had a lot of those in the past
luckily for for both of the original
sins so we're hoping we'll see that with
with vg3 also uh and it will be those
people that will will drive the game to
become much much better
than hopefully there already is i think
it's already pretty good but i know it
can be that much better once people
start playing
it and we see literally okay well we
didn't think of that we didn't think of
that that button should be there it
should not be there that kind of thing
uh these fights are too hard hey why did
nobody ever think of this id
like why didn't we put this in there so
when we put that group thinking into it
you will get a much better game and
we're committed
to to listening and integrating stuff it
will take us some time of course we
can't just magic it out of our
or out of thin air but we will be
listening and we will be integrating
things that we see are
are makes sense or we think are going to
be good for the gameplay
not everything because everything but a
lot for sure
no and the fact that you've got 20 plus
hours of content in there i mean this is
you know a very
you know meaty experience for fans that
they they can't
wait um to jump into it again the
production value looks incredible with
all you know
the cinematics and dialogue and
everything so i think uh
we're almost at that point sven where i
think you need to
get that world premiere button ready
because uh are you ready to tell the
world when uh early access is coming
yeah i guess so hello all right that's
uh
oh no i hit the wrong one oh my god oh
my god this
is too too perfect that's my cue to get
out of here
let me try that again come here
oh it's the wrong one all right well
anyway
all right let me do it properly all
right so
premiere
so the date that we're targeting for the
moment and we think we have a really
good chance of hitting is
september 30th so on september 30th
hopefully you will find a game that's
gonna be fun to play from day one
and we'll still see a lot of
improvements that is waiting for your
feedback waiting for your data
uh and in which uh if anything you
should really try playing as an evil
character and see all the cool things
that are going to happen to you because
it has a enormous amount of
permutations because what we said the
word permutations a lot
so september 30th for pc and for stadia
simultaneously
and uh yeah coming
all right 30th all right they say that's
it's going to be
clipped out on twitch so you got to
stick to it now but yeah all right so
and this is a temperature
for early access but again like i think
the scale of what you guys are doing i
was
when we first started talking to you
guys about this earlier this year i was
like amazed how far
along you guys were with the game and
then the fact that uh you know you're
gonna hit
with this you know the act one content
in six weeks is amazing so
um i think we all can't wait to see
everything that's in there
um we've got a bunch of questions for
you guys that uh we've been grabbing
from
the streams on twitch and youtube from
fans so the community
conversation you guys are always great
about talking to the fans but i'm just
going to go through some of these for
you guys
um based on what the fans are saying and
just
uh get some reactions here for maybe
like the next 15 minutes or so
um so let's just jump into them um
the first one comes from uh
matthias on youtube and he says what
have you guys done to preserve
the dnd tabletop spirit in
bg three
you want to pick adams yeah i'll take
that yeah i mean uh
it's it's it's the entire studio
uh is this uh bringing it to life so
i talk a lot about uh this idea of being
your dm
and that's really really true that's
like that that comes from the heart
um we want you to feel as if you're
playing
with us not that we're just telling you
our story but
you're playing it with us and that's
very very true to my experience with
tabletop dnd and then there's all the
people who are far far smarter at this
stuff than me
who are working to interpret systems uh
spells classes
it's an incredible amount of work and i
i just i live in dnd now uh you know i i
spend my days reading law i spend my
days going back into the history you
know this is the world i live in right
now
and uh and and sharing it is is a real
privilege you know
like um it's it's it's such an expansive
uh and brilliant place and you can
already see with some of the choices
we've made
uh we want to explore the strange
corners we want to go to a vernon so we
want to put you on a naughty lloyd um
we want to we want to yeah we want to
really bring this to life for all of you
you've also tapped into some very classy
monsters
like the mind players the alberts
the intellect of hour i mean these are a
lot of monsters
we haven't seen we haven't seen an
intellect of hour in a game before
so this is already we're seeing
something from classic dnd brought to
life for the first time it's great
yeah yeah there's a there's a very very
very strong
uh push and a lot of pressure actually
inside of studio
to reward players agency regardless of
what choices they made
uh make sure that there's always
something for them and so
when you put just set and actually what
what chris just said also making sure
that all those iconic creatures and
locations are coming into the game
when you put all of that together you
feel like you're playing
hopefully a a tabletop session with a
virtual game master and that just
reacts naturally to whatever your
choices were as a party and it's great
in multiplayer but it's also great in
single player
awesome uh all right next question comes
from twitch
and this is from the tboyce uh
and this person wants to know which is a
great question what kind of feedback
are the most helpful for you guys from
early access what is the best method for
gamers to share their thoughts and
impressions with larian
um so how do you guys want people to you
know they're obviously super devoted to
helping you guys here what's
what's most helpful okay
so uh just playing is already very
helpful
so you don't have to do anything because
we are well actually oh yeah i lost my
ear
uh so someone's gonna have to put back
the year because i can't with the armor
but uh just playing with
well i still have the left ear so i can
hear you and moon oh my god
if you just play the game you you you
you
yeah you're gonna be on the camera if
you click uh
on yes i want to send data to larian the
only data that we're getting is game
data from winning the game or data when
you crash uh
that is already super helpful um if you
want to go further
there's a variety of ways that you can
reach us you can reach us on social
media you can reach us
on our own forums learning forums you
can reach us on the steam forums
and just basically write your faults
there we will pick it up we have a
community team
and they're looking at everything that
people are um
are saying and doing and so we we
analyze this so
and if somebody had an id you can rest
assured that somebody
in our slack channel is going to tell us
like that was a great idea you should
really
listen to that and so that is a um
yes that is the thing you're going to a
way that you will be able to reach us
and in a much less professional sense i
look everywhere i absorb your memes i
love them
please keep creating them to us you know
i i watch you i listen to you
uh but that's just me
we are definitely looking at what's
happening on reddit so
i'm i'm sure there there's gonna be lots
of folks giving feedback um
there's also a question that just came
in from discord um another popular place
to talk about it
this is from the wizard and wizard wants
to know will you add more races and
classes
during ea uh or is what we get the first
day
all we can try out a great question
about sort of how early access is going
to evolve at least from a content
perspective
what can you share about that okay so
yeah no classes are going to be added
throughout ea companions will be added
races will be added features will be
added so
a lot of the stuff that we advertised is
present in early access but there's more
that we haven't advertised yet
and so you will see things pop in at the
same time you'll see the game change
as we take the feedback into account
whatever the feedback is going to be so
i can't
predict it up front but you you will see
a lot of change
if you if you want to have a a litmus
test of that or a a
point of reference uh you just look at
what we did the original sin too you
just
tried to play original sin two in early
access as we released it and then look
at the game that it's now
and so all the change that happened to
it and that's if something can happen to
bg3
with all of the content that gets added
to it also
i mean like originals into i think like
every month stuff was being added
and so you'll see similar things
happening with
awesome um next question
um comes from youtube uh viridi wants to
know where
will there be romance options when you
tell us about romance
again go ahead adam
yes they will uh i i don't want to say
too much about them because uh
you know we don't want to get into too
much spoiler territory romance is best
discovered
you know by yourselves uh you don't want
me to describe your romance who you want
to experience
but yes romance is a huge part of the
game
uh the campsite gets a little bit hot at
times that's that's absolutely true yeah
you discover some of it in early access
but we yeah
it's literally one that we want you to
discover but we actually went quite far
and then everything that we put in there
so people will find it after playing the
game
uh so uh i had no no doubt
that you have literally everything
although this next question is a good
one which i don't know if you've thought
of or it's possible
uh victor on youtube wants to know can
we pet the brain
yeah with your thumb you saw that
you probably will be able to tomorrow
now so
i was going to say you guys are
realistic there's still six weeks until
early access comes out
um another question comes from youtube
uh
about backgrounds for the custom
characters so
uh you know tell us a bit about that
like how how much can you pick or
build out kind of a you know background
origin story for characters
so there's a bunch of backgrounds in the
game
so they have systemic benefits which are
uh
going to to help your uh your characters
throughout the game
what we didn't do and because we did
start with it actually
uh we had backgrounds actually also give
you a a whole bunch of
options but then as we started
implementing the dialogue we actually
had
quite a lot of problems with that
because um full full hero for instance
you got a tag option inside of a
dialogue that says folk hero
and then the question from the writer
was yeah but sure but why are you folk
hero what did you do as a folk hero how
do you get here as a folk hero
and so from the dialogue option point of
view
the background options that were put
into the game i saw the uh we focused
heavily on the classes and the races
uh and obviously on the things that
you've done and earned throughout the
game
but we didn't put the backgrounds in
there but at the systemic level
backgrounds do have an impact
uh across all of your classes
okay good to know um next question you
sort of hinted at this earlier
um for lark
arn wants to know have all the
recruitable companions been revealed are
there more to come
and will the roster be comparable to
previous
baldur's gate games uh sounds like there
will be more added right
yeah there will be more there won't be
as many as the previous ballers gate
games because we put a lot of extra
stuff
on our companions if you compare it uh
just the relationship because we have a
when people will see and they'll start
playing it you'll see the enormous
amount of relationship
options that are there and how far they
go so there will be less
but there are more coming as a matter of
fact adam is working very hard on his
uh and that one is not in the game yet
so not announced either
and we'll just shut up yeah no no i
i'm super excited about i would talk
about it all night but obviously i
cannot
so all right um
next batch of questions here uh and
both these questions are uh about roles
and they come from youtube
and uh cronin um will there be a combat
log that shows the roles occurring
and also are there stats with modifiers
that get added
to dialogue roles uh
we can tell us about that guys yes i'm
sorry
go ahead yes all right simple yes answer
i think that's good news yeah all right
and then we've got
great okay um and we got one more
question for you guys
um let's see uh this one comes from
robert uh fulmer on youtube and he says
how interactive will the world be
for example could i shoot a chandelier
and it fall
on an uh very specific example but
uh the idea of you know dynamic
environments emergent gameplay
um you guys obviously are building an
amazing
systemic world so i imagine there are
some great emergent moments
um what are the kinds of things we can
expect in ea or
what are some of those opportunities
well you can i think i demonstrated that
in the previous gameplay
uh stream actually oh no i didn't show
it yeah it's right it was in others
yeah so yes i never showed it yeah yeah
so the answer is yes
yes yes yes so uh so it's like yes
you can you can you can
actually have a cool scene that we
demonstrated to press at some point
and where that was literally the thing
that saved the day in that particular
battle so uh
and so there's there's other stuff like
that that's coming in
i i want to quickly modify this finish
robert asked
uh could i shoot blurring it fall on my
enemy it's very important to note that
you can also shoot a chandelier and it
falls on your friend
very important to know that ah so
important
you can actually jump on your enemy from
if you were a spider you can just jump
from the top
on the enemy and then just give damage
to the enemy if you want
very authentic d experience
you guys have thought of it all um well
i have to say like
it's awesome the date for early access
end of september
um we're on the record with that it
looks
incredible right just the production
value of what you guys been able to do
especially you know that many dialogue
lines
in the middle of you know a pandemic
with all the recording i can't imagine
what's gone into all the cinematic stuff
and
you know obviously the gameplay uh to
get it to a point where you're
comfortable enough to have
people jump in for you know 20 plus
hours of gameplay
is is pretty incredible so um september
30th
on the record uh we will see everyone i
guess starting in hell
for uh early access on baldur's gate 3
and act
1. um want to thank sven and adam for
putting this stream together and the
whole team really at larian for the
incredible work
to put things together and chris uh
thanks for thanks for joining
us as well the one guy that wasn't in
hell today um
uh having a great fun on this and uh
yeah this is you know a big moment for
all of us that uh early access is coming
so
anything else you keep we say goodbye
here sven
no i mean like just uh if you want to
stay tuned
follow us on our social media it's
coming for pc stage september 30th
uh be sure if you if if you buy it that
it's something that you want to play
that you want to participate
it otherwise just wait until 1.0 it'll
take some time but when it 1.0 is gonna
hit it's gonna be pretty good
that's it i guess i gotta say it's uh
i've done a lot of live streams this
summer but
i have to say you take the cake in terms
of the setup and the fire and the armor
and what happens after the stream it's
pretty hot this is
just what this is just what my office
looks like this is normal
the people who decorated this the people
behind the scenes thank you to everyone
like this is hard to do as well during
these times you know we
we are socially distancing we are kobe
compliant it takes a lot of work to put
the bill together thanks to everyone who
helps out with that as well
really appreciate it agreed it's uh
guys you're gonna give people something
to check out end of september so
september 30th
early access for baldur's gate three
thanks for
watching the stream and uh stay tuned to
valerian socials for more updates on
that early access day
uh in boulder's gate three thanks for
watching everybody thanks chris
thanks jen thanks adam thank you
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you